a local teen's self-made documentary is
going international this weekend it
features people from right here in las
vegas who have an impact on the lgbtq
community victoria saha spoke with her
today she joins us with a look at what
this documentary means for las vegas
victoria hey sasha it's called las vegas
exploring the past present and hope for
gender diverse community here in vegas
and it was all made possible by a 13
year old girl we are pleased to announce
your film you presented at the 75th
international film festival of soleno
has been selected for the competition
words that 13-year-old bella
castellerian was waiting for her
documentary was selected out of 8 000
applicants from across the globe it's
called las vegas if you're gay probably
very scary times
you're not your punching dad i'm not a
trans female i'm not a girl i'm not a
boy
i'm roxy there's a law that isn't in
place to support you than changed a lot
[Music]
i hope
hearing these stories and hearing from
them
people take in the fact that
this is what vegas really is beneath
everything bella identifies as queer
this teen has found herself amongst the
lgbtq community for a while as her older
brother kai is transgender while wanting
to know more about the trans community
in las vegas she found herself meeting
many local people who came across
adversity regarding their sexuality
inspiring her to create las vegas giving
them a platform to tell their story
the documentary will debut this weekend
at the salerno film festival in italy
bella chose an italian film festival
because her family has italian roots she
tells me she hopes this documentary will
help others feel comfortable having
conversations about gender diversity